so when you work for the feds you have
to do something called Outsider approval
to get outside employment because they
got to make sure you don't do a conflict
of interest or whatever you can't work
at a defense law firm if you're a
criminal investigator right so they got
to make sure they clear it and then I
moved to Miami started up the podcast
and they brought me in and they're like
hey you know you're saying controversial
stuff on the internet you got to pick
one and then you know ended up going the
entrepreneurial route as YouTube started
to take off that's kind of why I had to
make my decision of what I'm gonna do at
the time working for the government I
was making about 120 130 000 per year so
when I left the government I was like
damn I'm losing out on a six-figure
career what am I going to do here I need
to replace it with real estate which
actually I watched your video how to buy
real estate step by step which that
helped quite a bit Yeah Yeah pull that
money out of my tsp and bought that
first property and yeah ended up working
out